what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have an update from Jason
Momoa the current Aquaman about his
future with DC and DC's future in
general and it's very good he is very
excited however it is kind of a cryptic
message and I think a lot of people are
kind of misinterpreting this however
like I said Jason Momoa does seem very
excited about the future of DC
specifically his future with DC and it
does look like he has signed on for
another four years he recently met with
James Gunn and Peter saffron it looks
like at Warner Brothers and he posted
this story basically celebrating check
it out four years four years ago I had
the jeep out front yeah yeah no no four
years ago I was screaming wasn't it yeah
screaming when I left Warner Brothers
all right everyone's in the MIDI
four years again it's a mystery baby we
got uh I got some really good news
great news with Warner Brothers amazing
um wish I could tell you but here it is
Peter I love you James I love you
David
okay mwah
to the Future to the Future
so as you can see here Jason Momoa is
clearly very excited and he just met
with Warner Brothers where he talked to
Peter Safran and James Gunn in which he
expresses that he loves them both he
also says another four years he says
four years again but then he says it's a
mystery baby I wish I could tell you now
if you've been keeping up sort of with
DC news he might be referring to Lobo
James Gunn has kind of hinted that Jason
Momoa could be playing Lobo in the new
DC Universe and I think this is becoming
more and more true one Jace Momoa does
look like he would indeed be a perfect
Lobo the resemblance between the two of
them is uncanny but we also know that
James Gunn is sort of doing a soft
reboot getting a younger cast to play
the members of the Justice League like
Superman so we could probably assume
that he's going to do the same for
Wonder Woman and Aquaman which means
Aquaman 2 would most likely be the end
of Jason Momoa playing Aquaman but if
he's on for another four years that
means he is most likely indeed going to
play Lobo in the DC Universe it also
sounds like the future of DC is probably
going to be pretty dang good if Jason
Momoa is this excited about the future
so I'm really excited to hear the update
from James Gunn which is most likely
coming soon since Jason Momoa just met
with him and heard basically the plan
that James Gunn is going to tell us very
soon the word right now is that it could
be possibly coming next week but keep in
mind James Gunn did say in January he
was going to give us some reveals so
hopefully next week but if not the week
after James Gunn did say January so
we're getting pretty close so let us
know all of your thoughts about the new
DCU that is coming in the comments down
below and don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos about the DC
Universe for live updates you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf